I have a prediction that marriages
without kids are happier than marriages
with kids now Studies have been done
kids for sure diminish your overall life
satisfaction it might come back like
when you're in your 60s but from like
the time you have your kid until after
all of them have left the house for a
significant period of time it diminishes
your overall sense of well-being so
having kids is the ultimate Act of
sacrifice it's beautiful it's wonderful
amazing and I hope people do it I think
it is the most obious vious life path to
go down if you want to be fulfilled but
there is another side to that coin and
it's pretty bright and sunny over on my
side of the road